I'm Cyril Vanier in Doha the top story
on Al Jazeera breaking news this hour
coming from Iranian State media it
appears that Iran and Saudi Arabia have
agreed to re-establish ties diplomatic
ties and reopen embassies in two months
time our correspondent in Tehran Ali
Hashem joins us now Ali what can you
tell us at this stage
well uh this morning we heard and we
read the news that there is a big robots
who didn't know on which uh on which
prompt whether it's on the nuclear front
or the Saudi Arabian plant and then the
latest news coming out from Iran's
Supreme National Security Council that
the Secretary of this Council Ali
shankhani was in Beijing in China where
he met the his counterparts how did
counterpart and they agreed on the
resuming relations diplomatic relations
within becoming two months what we
understood is that the uh the Chinese
government was mitiated between the two
sides and that during
president's visit to China
um
spotted now more details are to come in
the coming hours but there was already
attacked between Saudi Arabia and Iraq
this is not coming out of you in the
past couple of years there were meetings
between charity and Iranian officials in
Baghdad in Iraq and there was an
immigration that the Iraqi government uh
partnered back in 2021 however with the
Iraqi elections in 2021 and October 2021
everything stopped them there was no
real news coming out of this stock
knowing things it was like five rounds
of talk and then there was nothing but
what was known and this is this is what
the secret is that there were security
meetings meetings on security level in
Oman and they were mainly concentrating
on
um coordinating over the situation in
Yemen but for now this is big news for
the region because Iran is Saudi Arabia
has been not enjoying good relations for
the past seven years since 2016 when
relations between the two countries were
severe after an attack on the Saudi uh
Embassy here in Tehran by uh um
protesters so it seems then the utaudi
um the broader diplomatic Mission and
other Gulf countries did the same and
the situation started uh escalating
between the two countries but a lot of
files between the intersecting fight
with a lot of differences in regions
like like Lebanon like Syria and of
course in Yemen
Alia as you say this is Major news for
the region we're talking about the the
two big Regional Rivals uh what do we
think brought us to this point you
mentioned negotiations in Iraq you
mentioned there have been contacts you
mentioned there have been multiple
countries third-party countries that
were involved but what do you think are
are the the bigger contextual uh
elements that allow these two rival
countries to now come to this point
well you know when these two
kind of tense situation between them but
the uh security situation in the region
we deteriorated Lebanon and Yemen and
Iraq all these countries had to uh uh to
suffer from these differences now it's
possible that we see kind of compromises
that are going to start in these
countries and then this is going to
create a better situation maybe in the
region with both countries having a lot
of Leverage in federal areas and they're
having also a kind of
approving uh interest in all these areas
also all right Ali Hashem reporting from
Tehran thank you very much and just a
reminder of yours who are just joining
us we're learning from Iran's State
media that Iran and Saudi Arabia have
decided to re-establish ties and reopen
embassies we'll bring you more on this
when we